hallo herzlich willkommen zur ersten
folge meines neuen format krieg ist
kitchen jack's heute zeige ich euch acht
lebensmittel die ihr eventuell sogar
falsch lagert die ihr sie richtig lagert
kommen wir zum lebensmittel numero eins
das habt ihr wahrscheinlich alle zuhause
es handelt sich um brot ich habe
letztens meiner freunde sind die habt
ihr brot im kühlschrank aufbewahrt und
ich hab gedacht nein nein das geht nicht
brot im kühlschrank nicht vorstellen ist
ein stärkere moleküle enthalten und die
geben wasser ab das hat sie zum
wahnsinnig wissenschaftlich an aber im
endeffekt ist für euch nur wichtig dass
brot wird richtig schnell alt und das
ist mega schade und ihr mann ist am
besten so dass ihr euer brot umfeld von
dieser plastikverpackung in ganz normale
brot hüten die auch vom bäcker kennt die
brot tüten sind optimal denn die
entziehen zwar ein bisschen feuchtigkeit
geben aber auch ein bisschen luft ab die
luft kann zirkulieren und optimal und so
bewahrte sie dann auf zimmertemperatur
auf perfekte temperatur ist übrigens 18
bis 22 grad
[Musik]
gibt nummer zwei gewürze gewürze lagert
in natürlich das wisst ihr alle schön
luftdicht ich habe dafür vorratsdosen
und ganz ganz ganz wichtig trocken und
kühl lagern und ihr dürft nicht den
fehler machen und das ganze über
verlagern und am herd so wollte ich das
nämlich erstmal habe ich dann um
entschieden denn die hitze vom herd
macht eure gewürze schlimmstenfalls
kaputt punkt nummer drei wer kennt nicht
ich kannte das vor allem von früher also
ein bisschen jünger war
ich habe immer petersilie da gehabt weil
ich bitte sie da ich zu allem möglichen
mag aber es wurde ja schnell schlecht im
kühlschrank gibt euch jetzt den
ultimativen tipp lagert es genauso wie
frische blumen einfach in wasser
hochkant also ich steckt sie einfach
rein lasst sie dann auf zimmertemperatur
und so halten sie viel viel länger
das könnt ihr auch mit dem mache mit
schnittlauch mit allem möglichen bei
salatblättern mache ich immer anders da
verlangsame ich den foul prozess sei
weil die auch nicht so lange halten
ich wasche sie ganz gut trocknen sie
sehr gut ab und wickle sie dann ganz
locker um ein sauberes küchentuch und
gibt sie dann in den kühlschrank und
zwar ins untere fach
tipp nummero vier wir machen jetzt
tomaten und paprika mag ein bisschen
länger haltbar weil es auch sehr gerne
und sehr schnell schimmel ich kenne das
zu gut und zwar nehme ich mir immer
paprika mark in so großen gläsern und da
ist es wichtig dass jetzt ein teig
schaber nimmt und das ganze säubert und
so weit wie möglich nach unten durch das
mache ich jetzt als allererstes
[Musik]
und dann versiegelt ihr die oberfläche
mit öl und zack habt ihr wieder ein paar
wochen mehr haltbarkeit auf geht's zu
tipp nummer fünf also käse haben wir
immer im kühlschrank immer immer immer
wie ein richtiger käse freaks und
deshalb zeige ich euch mal wie ich es
früher auf erwartet und wie das niemals
aufwand dürft jetzt habe ich hier zum
beispiel ganz normalen scheiben käse
gibt das hier in meine frischhaltefolie
und jetzt passiert folgendes der käse
kann nicht atmen der weg an zu schwitzen
und zack ist er weniger haltbar und ihr
müsst ihn sofort wegschmeißen
daher mein tipp nimmt wachs papier so
kennt man das ja auch von käsetheken
wachs papier locker einfach drum herum
wickeln und dann damit keine gerüche
annimmt und trotzdem noch mal ein
bisschen geschützt ist in eine
frischhaltedosen sack ist euer krise
länger haltbar
was habt ihr ist kein backpapier genau
ganz anders wird jetzt fetakäse zum
beispiel gelagert oder schafskäse oder
hier im käse was auch immer das lager
tier nicht sowie den gouda käse den
hierzu gerade haltbarer gemacht habe er
macht dafür eine salzlake die kommen ja
auch in salzlake und dafür nimmt ihr
einfach zum beispiel einen liter wasser
und 150 gramm salz das ist eine
15-prozentige salzlake das kocht ihr
einmal auf und lasst es vollständig
abkühlen und ich gebe das hier auch wer
in eine frischhaltedosen und breche das
jetzt hier in grobe stücke gibt das rein
und dann kommt das in den kühlschrank
und hält so auch wieder viel viel länger
[Musik]
kommen wir zu tipp nummer 6 und jetzt
schreibt immer alle in die kommentare
sie lagert in zitronen jetzt ich warte
habt ihr lager sie immer im kühlschrank
was sehr falsch ist ich mache seit ein
paar monaten anders ich musste das alles
auch selbst erst lernen das bekommt man
ja nach und nach somit und ich sage es
jetzt nur noch auf zimmertemperatur denn
so hans zitrusfrüchte am liebsten daher
einfach schön in einem korb und ich muss
auch sagen die sehen ja auch schön aus
ist das nun hamza schön gelb schon
dekorativ schön frisch hier noch ein
paar orangen dazu perfekt so gibt um eur
7 es geht um zwei best friends tomaten
und gurken aber im döner beim salat aber
ich muss auch ehrlich sagen die beiden
vertragen sich gar nicht so gut wie wir
mal alle dachten die haben so ein
bisschen dies miteinander denn ihr dürft
tomaten und gurken nicht zusammen lagen
das habe ich auch bestimmt schon gehört
das geht ja gott sein total rom denn
tomaten stoßen das gas ethylen aus
während sie nach reifen und das ist
nicht förderlich für die gurten daher
durch die immer ganz weit weg und zeigt
euch jetzt wie ich tomaten lager nicht
im kühlschrank die tomaten haben es bei
ca 15 grad am liebsten und nicht
übereinander gestapelt sondern
nebeneinander dass sie auch viel platz
haben so fertig wir kommen zum
allerletzten tipp zu kartoffeln ihr habt
doch bestimmt alle kartoffeln zu hause
und falls ihr bis hierhin irgend ein
tipp noch nicht kannte dann schreibt sie
noch jetzt in die kommentare
und bei kartoffeln ist es so die dürfte
nicht in den kühlschrank tun das ist
ganz klar
die dürfen aber auch nicht zu warm
gelagert werden ja was macht man jetzt
wenn es im sommer draußen warm ist und
dann ist ja automatisch hier in den
schränken auch alles so ein bisschen
warm ideal wären tatsächlich zehn grad
dennoch aber nicht im kühlschrank weil
der kühlschrank zu feucht ist deshalb
mache ich so nimmt man das halt in kauf
dass es im sommer ein bisschen wärmer
ist ich mache es so dass ich sie
entweder in seinem stand sei mit löchern
oder in seiner kiste mit löchern findet
ihr im büro bedarf dass ich sie da lager
damit sie auch genug luft bekommen und
dann gebe ich sie ganz einfach in
schrank das auch schön dunkel ist und
ein bisschen kühler als wenn die
erzählung vor auf oberflächen stehen
das wird noch dieses genau die
supermärkte lagern ja auch von
vornherein alles schon richtig
[Musik]
und das waren meine acht tipps die
allererste folge kikis kitchen hacks es
war eine basic folge falls ihr weitere
tipps und weitere folgen sehen möchtet
dann hinterlasst mir unbedingt feedback
damit ich auch weiß ob ich das
interessiert oder auch nicht und
schreibt mir auf jeden fall was ihr auf
diesem video mit genommen habt und was
sie schon kannte
und ansonsten würde ich mich natürlich
freuen wenn die zweite folge auch bald
kommt wenn in diesem video ein
kostenloses abo hinterlasst einfach
passt ihr nämlich auch nichts mehr
und dann sehen wir uns beim nächsten
video ob sie ein rezept ist ein blog
oder eine neue folge ging s kitchen
jack's das bleiben noch im verborgenen
dass sie beim nächsten mal tschüss eure
ki